one of the things I find most curious
about eight-year-olds writing is the way
that he plays with established themes if
you are somewhat familiar with one piece
you will know that there are many
elements in the story that Oda borrows
from outside sources and that often
follow certain patterns some of these
themes serve as an underlying message
while others are simply a method of
consistent storytelling most stories
make use of this principle and that
inevitably leads to a general exhaustion
of many of these themes in contemporary
works especially in fiction we often
find the same ideas and elements
recycled over and over again what Oda
does differently here is that he
integrates these widely spread ideas and
takes them a step further some of them
he gives a twist while others he
explores in a different context a
perfect example of this method of
writing is Sanji being one of the major
figures in the serious Sanji unites a
whole bunch of ideas inside of his
character and following it can sometimes
feel like it's full of contradictions in
this video we will explore how oda
constructed Sanji to be a true gentleman
and how he subtly twists a stereotype in
certain ways to turn Sanji into a
fascinating character that finds itself
conflicted with its ideals and values in
this context we will also take a closer
look at the true purpose of the whole
cake island arc and discuss why our
passionate cook is such an important
part of the straw hat crew before we can
decide though if Sanji truly is a
gentleman in every sense of the word we
must first understand what being a
gentleman actually means the term
gentleman nowadays is often confused for
individual superficial acts of
politeness you sometimes hear guys being
called a gentleman for basically not
behaving like an [ __ ]
but being a gentleman has nothing to do
with holding open the door for a woman
nor with being a man it is much rather
determined by person's overall behavior
and mindset becoming a gentleman is
something that takes a strong conviction
as well as a lot of time and effort
there are a whole bunch of qualities
that make a true gentleman
these include chivalry compassion and
kindness
Becht bravery loyalty and cleverness
being a gentleman therefore means being
respectful and tolerant in interaction
with others while putting their
interests before your own but why would
anyone want to go through all that in
the first place though there are several
reasons why it might be worth to strive
for becoming a gentleman obviously it
comes with a certain amount of altruism
and finding pleasure in helping others
this can mean helping and protecting
those who are in need or important to
you bringing positivity and kindness
into someone's life or simply inspiring
others to follow your example for
creating a more social and positive
environment but of course it also holds
benefit for you personally behaving in a
gentlemanlike manner to what others will
earn you the respect and trust of those
around you this again will in the end
inspire more positive behavior back
towards yourself as well creating a kind
of positive feedback loop for everyone
involved and if you spin this thought
even further and look at it from a
cultural perspective encouraging such
behavior may in the end result in a more
considerate and healthy society one that
actively seeks to be helpful helpful in
a genuine open and kind way and not in a
patronizing or superior way in other
words a gentleman and that can be anyone
is someone that unites a broad variety
of positive characteristics that benefit
those around them on the other hand what
you probably are also aware of though is
the fact that characters who are through
and through good are usually not the
ones we love and root for the most in a
story and we will later on also explore
what problems such a white knight can
bring with it in the context of
storytelling since people in the real
world are not that black or white we
tend to prefer characters that are
morally a little bit more gray so now
let's take a look whether Sanji actually
fulfills the requirements to be called a
true gentleman what implications that
has for his character and why he's so
essential to the story as a quick
disclaimer at this point if you aren't
caught up with the story of one piece
yet be careful because from now on this
video will contain spoilers for Sanji's
character arc being part of the monster
trio and one of the early members of the
crew Sanji is one of the most beloved
characters in the story
while his considerable fighting
abilities as well as his cool and
collected manner play a big part in this
Sanji's character has a high level of
complexity and therefore has a lot more
to offer over the years we have gotten
to know Sanji better and better and with
the events at hoecake Island we now
finally have a very full picture of why
Sanji became the person he is today so
now let's look at the five defining
character traits for Sanji and how they
qualify him to be the true gentleman of
the story the first trade that we will
look at is Sanji's cleverness while
inside the monster trio he might not be
considered quite as powerful as luffy
Ozora by some he often makes up for it
by fighting smarter Sanji often finds
himself wandering off alone during large
encounters only to discover secret doors
and weaknesses that he's able to exploit
for the crews benefit his curiosity and
cleverness often put him into situations
where he's able to save the rest of the
crew Sanji does so on the way to
alabaster posing as mr. three and giving
the crew a decisive edge against
crocodile as he's unknown to the baroque
works organization later on when the
rest of the crew was captured on
alabasta Sanji outwitted him again using
a tendon mushi he then repeats this feat
in Skye piya to wreak havoc on an old
ship from the inside and when Robin was
captured by the cp9 atwater seven Sanji
already figured they would take her to
the station and waited for them there
and later on Ennis Lobby he went off on
his own in order to close the gates of
Justice much rather than engaging with
the guards on the island in punk hazard
he left the group in order to save
Toshiki from Burgo but the most
significant case would most likely be
having to leave zou to spare his crew
from big mum's wrath by going and
confronting his family all these
examples show how Sanji uses his
cleverness in critical situations to
turn the table for his crewmates but we
also get to see some G's cleverness
outside of battle he's usually very
perceptive of things and seems to have a
good judgment when it comes to critical
situations being clever is essential to
being a true gentleman because
understanding situations and people and
knowing how to act appropriately is an
important trait in order to have
if influenced the second important
characteristic is Sanji's deep sense of
compassion and kindness
Sanji might be one of the kindest and
most empathetic characters in all of one
piece while we usually see Sanji
carrying himself in a very calm cool and
collected manner he's not someone to be
afraid of showing emotion and weakness
from time to time as a matter of fact we
have seen many characters admiring
Sanji's kind heart including his mother
his sister luffy and even brook who
stated Sanji is just too kind once he
decides to protect someone he will put
his life on the line for them despite
growing up under the terror of his
father and his brothers
Sanji always kept his strong sense of
compassion and generosity after he was
taken in by Zef these attributes were
imbued deep into his personality and
defined a lot of Sanji's decisions and
actions throughout the story next to the
people closest to him that he would go
to any lengths to in order to save them
or make them happy he also cares for
strangers this can be seen on various
occasions when Sanji goes out of his way
to save Dean at the Bharati a key naman
intertia Gyan Punk hazard the minks on
zou as well as she phoned from ovens
wrath on whole cake Islands he even
refused to leave his family behind that
cost him so much agony and pain in his
childhood and that had made use of him
to get close to big mom and he also
protected pudding at the wedding
ceremony despite being aware of her true
intentions as you can see Sanji cares
for friends and foes alike when a
situation calls for empathy and
compassion but his kindness probably is
most pronounced in his rule to never let
anyone go hungry no matter who they
might be after having experienced true
hunger himself he swore to himself to
not let anyone go through that if he can
help it his desire to help and protect
others is a central part of being a
gentleman and Sanji lives by this ideal
without a second thought
the third personality trait that is
defining for Sanji's character are
loyalty and respect similar to Zorro
Sanji also strongly believes in loyalty
not only what Sanji do anything for
those he loves but he also cited with
Zorro about a sob rejoining the crew
when the latter stepped on Luffy's
right it was there for so much worse for
him when he was the one to betray Luffy
and the crew later on zou obviously it
was a hard blow to his self-esteem when
he was faced with the choice between
leaving the crew or the life of his
mouth affect Father's F the internal
conflict that this decision has engulfed
Sanji in resulted in a lot of pain for
everyone involved
Sanji even claimed that he had lost the
right to return to the crew until Luffy
convinced him otherwise this already
shows us one of the problems with Sanji
strong ideals but we will get back to
that in a little bit hand-in-hand where
Sanji's loyalty goes a strong sense of
respect this obviously includes respect
for Zeff his captain and crew mates but
also sometimes respect for certain
enemies and of course
Sanji requires respect from anyone when
it comes to food and women we can see
the full extent of disrespect and
loyalty on Thrilla bark when he tries to
sacrifice himself for his captain before
Zorro steps in and knocks him out in
order to take on that responsibility
himself loyal and respectful behavior
are more than necessary features to be
considered a true gentleman after all
the next critical trade for Sanji are
his bravery and combat attitude without
a doubt we know that Sanji is strong
well there's always a lot of debate
going on over how everyone ranks in the
crew strength wise I think no one will
disagree that Sanji is one of the most
important competence on the crew usually
being fearless in battle he's often seen
fighting armies and powerful opponents
with barely more than a concerned look
and being part of the monster trio he
usually ends up fighting one of the
stronger Poland's in an arc despite
having significant battle skills though
different from Luffy or Zorro he usually
tries to avoid a direct confrontation
whenever possible and while we
definitely see him enjoying a battle at
times
Sanji usually only enters a fight to
protect or help someone else on Thrilla
bark for example he fights Absalom in
order to protect Nami and just recently
in one oh he immediately jumped in to
protect Coco from Shogun orochi's
attempt to kill her standing side by
side with sorrow having the wish and the
ability to fight for and protect others
are very important assets for any
gentleman
we have to take a closer look at Sanji's
chivalry which is in general an
essential part of being a gentleman but
has two very different sides in Sanji's
case in some cases Sanji can be seen
acting mature and cool around women
further supporting his image as a
gentleman in other cases though it can
get very excessive and pervy some people
think that his perverted nature is taken
too far and often crosses the line of
being comedic and sometimes even too
downright creepy and while I don't
disagree with that it's something that
in a manga you maybe have to accept as a
quirk to the character I personally
don't think that Sanji should lose the
sight of him completely but I think it
would allow more people to see him as a
great character if it were to be turned
down a little bit that being said over
the course of the story this has
somewhat improved especially by giving
Sanji some real experiences with women
like viola pudding that have helped him
mature a little bit in this regard this
excessive behavior aside though Sanji in
general has a very respectful and
chivalrous attitude towards women this
even goes so far that next to feeding
anyone who's hungry
Sanji second big rule in life is not to
hurt or fight any woman
this attitude most likely developed
under the influence of his sister a Jew
who was the only positive influence in
his childhood as well as Zeff who held
strong ideals by himself as a result he
becomes infuriated with anyone going
against this ideal this can for example
be seen inside the Germans castle when
he found Cosette brutally beaten to the
point of unconsciousness
Sanji became absolutely furious he went
on to fight Nietzsche and ended up
breaking his jaw all that despite the
threats and warnings his family issued
towards him all these qualities his
cleverness his compassion his kindness
his loyalty and respect his bravery as
well as his chivalry make Sanji into a
true gentleman someone that the people
around him can truly rely on what then
is the problem with his codex that Sanji
follows and how did it affect his
character not only story-wise but also
in the eyes of many fans like all the
other straw hats
Sanji also follows a dream for which he
joined luffy on his journey finding the
legendary all blue a sea were fish from
all over the world are gathered together
what makes this dream so much different
from all the other straw hats though is
that this is not really a dream that you
can truly make any tangible progress
towards over the course of the journey
finding a place is different from
becoming stronger or better at what you
do and we also pretty much never see
Sanji making any active efforts to find
out more about his dream so in other
words his development over the story is
usually more for other people than for
himself
Sanji doesn't have the motivation to
become stronger just for the sake of it
his goal is completely unrelated to his
character
what's angie strife so much rather is to
uphold his ideals and be a true
gentleman a knight on a white horse
well this in its own way is also a very
difficult and noble task in a story like
one piece that not only is focused
around personal growth but also is
incredibly long it can be difficult to
cheer for a character that strives for
staying the same rather than changing we
enjoy seeing Luffy training to get new
skills and Zoro learning new techniques
what is easy to overlook though is Sanji
struggle with his morality and values
having a list of rules to live by some
might argue that this works against the
character if he never breaks that rule
then how can there be conflict how can
that character not seem static and
boring but in my opinion that is simply
not true
Sanji's actual curse is that he's always
compared to Zorro and Luffy since he has
comparable fighting power there is the
strong expectation for him to similarly
strive for more strength but I think
it's important to realize that Sanji's
personality and character arc are just
extremely different from these two one
piece is after all not only a story
about characters being changed by the
world but it's also in many ways a story
about the world being changed by the
characters Sanji again and again comes
into conflict with his ideals his
conviction to not fight women under any
circumstances often hinders him from
helping and protecting those around him
this can for example be seen in his
fight against Khalifa from cp9 during
the Ennis Lobby arc and the conflict
between his loyalty towards eff and his
loyalty towards his crew and up in the
whole cake island arc which purpose has
been deeply misunderstood exactly for
the same reason people thought that the
arc was all about Sanji
stronger and catching up to Luffy and
Zorro and there was a lot of
disappointment when that didn't happen
but as we just saw that's not what this
character is actually about whole cake
island was Sanji's arc because his
ideals that he strives to keep up
finally pushed him into a moral corner
where he had no choice but to change he
had to experience the problems and pain
that sticking to his ideals could mean
and he had to learn and accept to trust
his captain and his crew in order to be
able to keep them alive in the future in
other words
Sanji had to grow as a character to stay
loyal to his values so the next time you
read the whole cake island arc I ask you
to keep that in mind and try to look at
the events from that perspective you
will see that the entire arc gets an
entirely new gravity for Sanji's
character when you stop looking at him
the same way you would look at Zorro a
Luffy Sanji is a fascinating character
because his personality and his combat
skills make his character seem
inconsistent and contradictive at times
but it's important to realize how great
it is for destroy at KU to have someone
as kind and compassionate as Sanji on
the crew that also has the power to act
upon it so despite being close to luffy
and Zorro in terms of combat ability his
character arc is very different and
unique inside the crew being a true
gentleman brings many challenges and
hardships with it but it also makes
Sanji so incredibly important for the
true and the entire story plus he can
cook what else could anyone ask for hey
everybody thank you so much for watching
I feel like there often is a lot of
competition between Sanji and Zorro fans
but I personally think that there's no
issue in loving both characters for
different reasons yes both can fight but
apart from that both of them have
amazingly complex and interesting
personalities and ideals and I think
that both will be equally important to
help Luffy and the crew reach their
goals in the future what are your
thoughts on his character though and
what other defining moments can you
think of let me know your thoughts in
the comments below
starting this week you can also support
me and my work on patreon if you're
interested in helping me make more
embedded videos you can find a link to
my page in the description below you
will get free access to all of my
artwork and early access to my major
videos if you like this video don't
forget to like share and subscribe to be
notified for any future
kontin of mine or dislike don't share
and unsubscribe it's a free world people
I hope to see Iran next time and until
then have a great week
oh yeah and don't forget to turn your
notifications on because YouTube can
sometimes be forgetful bye
you
[Music]